se mi svegliassero di notte
il viso mi dicessero pierpaolo che cos'è
l'architettura io probabilmente
risponderei segno più funzione grotta
funzione segno croce grotta più croce
chiesa grotta più bandiera municipio ma
se invece me lo chiedessero invece la
mattina più o meno che cos'è
l'architettura allora probabilmente
risponderei una cosa un po più complessa
e direi che l'architettura è quella cosa
che in qualche maniera raduna le cose
del mondo pensate all'anfiteatro greco
ne abbiamo uno qua vicino a taormina in
quel piccolo arco di pietra c'è l'idea
della democrazia c'è l'idea del teatro
cioè in qualche maniera si sintetizza un
intero mondo ora insomma più o meno
all'architettura è quella facoltà o
forse quel bisogno squisitamente
antropologico di trasferire nello spazio
fuori di noi dei significati se però mi
chiedessero che cos'è l'architettura
diciamo dopo una birra dopo due birre
puramente dello stretto io direi che
l'architettura fondamentalmente sono
storie senza una storia che la racconta
le pietre rimangono le pietre
ora noi oggi viviamo probabilmente un
momento in cui l'architetto abbiamo
trasferito questa facoltà di abitare il
mondo e abbiamo trasferita
fondamentalmente saperi tecnici alle
autorità politiche ai potentati
economici
insomma non saprei come dirla meglio
però noi abitiamo il mondo da centinaia
d'anni prima che esistessero gli
architetti e probabilmente tutte le
città più belle del mondo sono state
fatte prima dei piani regolatori ancora
oggi
insomma in qualche mea ci hanno
sottratto questa possibilità di
interpretare lo spazio e allora io oggi
sono qua fondamentalmente per raccontare
due storie
una storia avviene a los angeles nel
quartiere di watts è uno degli infiniti
quartieri invisibili di quello che
quelli bravi dicono il paradigma
spazializzato della contemporaneità che
la città modernità istantanea e accanto
ai quartieri con beverly hills come
hollywood ci sono infiniti quartieri che
le guide specializzate vis consigliano
di andare tranne forse uno awards dove
un signore nel 1921 un immigrato
italiano semi analfabeta decide di
ribellarsi in qualche maniera a questo
destino di funzione edilizia popolare
scarsa e edifica nel suo terreno
queste fantastiche in qualche maniera
torri la cui alpes la cui più la più
alta e alta 33 metri lavora
incessantemente per 33 anni ora voi
dovete un attimino immaginare cosa vuol
dire ogni giorno senza scala per 33 anni
trovare materiale di riciclo un campo
una mattonella un pezzo di ferro un po
di cemento non aveva più le impronte
digitali dopo 33 anni è costruito e
costruisce queste enigmatiche direi
torri che non si capisce bene che cosa
sono
alcuni dicono che sono una metafora
delle barche di colombo quando è andato
in america in quanto emigrato alcuni
dicono che rappresentano una cosa
popolare del suo territorio
insomma quello che è interessante notare
io ripeto non sono un architetto mentre
sono più le reazioni che al corpo
sociale rispetto all'architetto quello
che è interessante notare è che quando
ci sono stati nel 1065 la prima grande
ribellione afroamericana in america nel
quartiere di watts il quartieri watts è
stato messo a ferro e fuoco
tranne che le watch tower che sono state
trattate in qualche maniera
una chiesa laica ora è difficile capire
cosa significa che queste torri vi do
due interpretazioni la prima la data
probabilmente più importante e biografo
della città di los angeles mike davis il
quale dice la città di los angelse
grande più o meno quanto le marche per
intenderci e per chilometri e chilometri
e chilometri non ha un'architettura
simbolica nello spazio pubblico nei
quartieri l'unica sono le watchtower
quindi lui dice non è un'architettura
come le altre della cellula sanges
questa è l'architettura di los angeles
un'altra interpretazione c'era da don de
lillo il famoso scrittore di underworld
che quando capita di fronte a queste
torri e non è facile andare a watch dice
le chiama le jazz tower ora jazz è una
definizione abbastanza fantastica perché
allude al quart di watts per assonanza
ma allude anche al passato afroamericano
del del quartiere ma soprattutto oggi
ogni settembre c'è un importantissimo
jazz festival
esattamente sotto queste torri insomma
io non saprei come come dirla
diversamente ma probabilmente un signore
se mi anarchico semina alpha beta
trovando il coraggio di cambiare
l'ambiente intorno a sé ha prodotto
effetti positivi per il quartiere più di
quanto hanno fatto le politiche sociali
le pianificazioni per non parlare delle
politiche securitarie ma se questa
storia vi sembra eccezionale a un certo
punto di vista in realtà non lo è perché
sono veramente migliaia le persone che
in qualche maniera modificano l'ambiente
intorno a sé chi ce la raccontate
meravigliosamente è un antropologo
italiano che fa un sito tra l'altro
consultabili costruttore di babele e
solo in italia né mappati almeno 120 non
c'è una regione italiana sprovvista di
un costruttore di babele me ne faccio
vedere un paio
qua siamo nelle cinque terre è un
signore ex ferroviere e costruisce ogni
natale un fantastico presepe per tutta
la collina cioè quelle colline così
abbandonati perché la gente va nelle
città tende a lasciare le colline che
tra l'altro crollano invece questo
signore riesce a come dire a regalare lo
sguardo e la bellezza paesaggistica di
di queste meravigliose terre
qua invece ci avviciniamo il viaggio
visto che siamo qua adesso si acquista
ma sciacca filippo bentivegna anche gli
le storie di migrazione torna nel suo
terreno in prevendita a sciacca proprio
edifica poi purtroppo è una sezione
migliaia migliaia di sculture cioè
rappresenta quasi un paese tra l'altro
che andava spopolandosi lui e riempie il
suo potere e lo riempie tra l'altro oggi
questa è un'attrazione turistica
tutelata dalla regione sicilia ma in
qualche maniera per omaggiare il tema è
soprattutto il luogo in cui siamo
vi voglio raccontare la storia del
costruttore babelico più famoso della
città di messina e siamo a maregrosso
siamo davanti alla
fantomatica casa delle meraviglie da
casa del puparo del cavaliere giovanni
cammarata che ci racconta in maniera
anche un po leggendario insomma uno dei
come dire delle ultime che attraversa il
secolo breve che fa cercare fortuna
all'estero lo catturano in guerra e
raccontano viene raccontato che lui una
volta prigionieri un campo di
concentramento
gli ufficiali che un po si annoiavano
probabilmente in un campo di
concentramento dicono ai prigionieri
chi di voi mi riesce riesce a divertirci
noi lo facciamo andare via e cammarata
allora incomincia a costruire fontane
castelli e grazie a questo lo lascino
tornare in patria
ora io non ci credo molto raccontava lui
queste cose non ci credo molto però
sicuramente lui si chiama cavaliere
cammarata per motivi di guerra e
sicuramente in questo fatto narrato c'è
un po la sintesi di quello che di tutta
la sua storia
cioè lui capisce che con l'arte
applicata al territorio si può
capovolgere la realtà
vi faccio una piccola zoomata di cose
che ci sono e vediamo che qua ci abbiamo
un fantastico don chisciotte e sancho
panza cavallo che sembra che combattono
contro i mulini a vento che hanno
devastato tutta la zona sud della città
di messina
qui c'è una imperiosa cavalcata di
elefanti gialli come diceva lui dove vi
invito a notare quanto lui fosse
consapevole della sua arte e quindi voi
sapete che i monumenti tendono a veri
piccioni sopra i monumenti quindi lui se
guardate la punta della proboscide ha
deciso di costruirsi un piccione giusto
per come dire tutto il cerchio oppure
eva di stefano lo definisce una disney
dialettale e riempie tutto quello spazio
funzionalizzato di babbi natali
biancaneve castelli insomma veramente un
come dire un motivo d'attrazione per un
quartiere che non avrebbe altri motivi
per andarci e infine l'opera ancora
integra questa è rimasta nel cortiletto
interno quella che mosè previti chiamò
alla madonna della birra messina perché
è una definizione veramente fantastica
perché negli anni 80 non c'era molto da
molte di vostro ricordano non c'era
molto da fare a messina
e allora uno dei riti e le andiamo a
vedere la casa del puparo e molto andava
non l'hai si facevano la birra della
staffa volta promesse di matrimonio ma
molti gli lanciava la birra lasciato la
bottiglia
cosa che poi come di una pratica che
rimane ancora oggi
e allora cammarata che ha fatto ha preso
tutti i cocci della birra messina è
affatto un fantastico mosaico però io
vorrei sottrarre la storia il cavaliere
cammarata la vorrei sottrarre dalla
dimensione meramente artisti che vorrei
un attimino intreccia con la storia
della città di messina
tutti sappiamo che il 1908 ha
rappresentato un trauma pazzesco per la
città di messina che viene ricostruita
su un impianto rettilineo
fondamentalmente guardate la via
garibaldi l'iva 12 mete prima che
fossero previste le macchine quindi si
dà un'interpretazione molto poco
siciliano di messina si vuole impiantare
una new towns una nuova città con
spazialità linee dritte e soprattutto
questa ricostruzione su cui ci sarebbe
veramente tanto da dire ci sono due
questioni fondamentali la prima come
potete vedere in questa immagine
la ferrovia come una lama taglia
completamente il mare da tutta la zona
sud della città di messina da mare
grosso appunto el altra questione è
quella che
insomma quando se fossimo po fuori a
prenderci rinfresco le chiameremo
baracche ma se noi le jamie lee b
troviamo architettura vernacolare
autocostruzione
insomma c'è un si sono fatte le carriere
sulle definizioni delle baracche però
però voi dovete pensare che una città
che viene allargata per le strade e
soprattutto da viene pensato su due
piani perché per invitare i crolli
fondamentalmente un'intera fascia
sociale viene espulsa dal centro
cittadino e viene segregata nei
quartieri giostra e mare grosso e questo
è esattamente fondo saccà cioè
esattamente a 20 metri dalla casa al cav
e cammarata quindi la sua operazione è
ancora più interessante perché invece di
accettare un destino urbanistico che
ancora oggi costringe un'intera fascia
sociale
lui si ribella e la trasforma in un
fantastico castello o appunto un parco
urbano
qua si può vedere maregrosso questa
penso che sia un'immagine veramente
straordinaria perché sembra la tavola di
un geometra ci sono solo parallelepipedi
è solo linea retta e sulla destra si
vede l'incredibile potenza dello stretto
di messina che dovrebbe essere la fonte
la ragione per cui la città in questo
momento è in questo scenario
monocromatico e rettilineo si vede ciò
che resta della casa di cammarata che è
una macchia di colore un festival della
curva un festival del simbolo cioè tutto
quello scusato secondo la zona sud di
messina non c'era più o meno prima del
terremoto
quindi la questione del terremoto ha
inciso sulla zona sud e un po sbagliata
se voi guardate le maglie sono una
scacchiera quello è stato con il futuro
pensato per la città di messina quindi
qua il terremoto va letto come un
accelerazione i processi non come una
sua frattura è insomma a questo punto
però cammarata non si limita a agire
dentro la sua casa ma si permette il
lusso che forse oggi è concesso
solamente i principi cioè cambia il nome
della via
invece di via mare grosso la chiama via
belle arti e incomincia a fare
dei murales insomma in qualche maniera
il primo street artist cittadino
possiamo dire che cammarata
vi invito a guardare alla vostra destra
c'è ulisse le sirene l'unico simbolo ma
ritmo in un quartiere che si chiama mare
grosso e probabilmente in tutta la zona
sud di messina è stato fatto esattamente
non dai linguaggi economici non dei
linguaggi politici non da linguaggi
scientifici ma da giovanni cammarata su
questa idea su questa idea allora la
domanda è che fare allora
allora qua la questione intreccia un po
la mia vita personale
questa casa coagula un po di non dico
intelligenza perché c'ero io però
diciamo un po di persone e si decide
invece che musealizzare la casa che tra
l'altro è difficile perché il comune non
sa se sua perché abusiva perché la
sovrintendente è veramente difficile
entrare in relazione allora decidiamo
decidiamo di fare quello che ha fatto
cammarata e in qualche maniera lanciamo
un concorso e una volta all'anno
impollinato maregrosso col linguaggio
artistico e qua vi faccio vedere alcune
delle opere fatte questo è un artista
catanese pochi tra l'altro in direzione
catania che riporta il terzo elefante da
combattimento è fatto vedere in foto non
è mai stato ritrovato mentre gli altri
due li ho ritrovati oggi sono la gam se
volete vederli ma la gamma è chiusa
se non rilevate avevo paura insomma è
rivolta e di porta e l'elefante qua cuma
un artista messinese decidere di portare
quel mare grosso negato dalla ferrovia
dai capannoni e sfrutta l'orizzontalità
del muro insomma e porta una fantastica
balena che non c'è più neanche questa
gli artisti per caso decidono di
omaggiare il linguaggio artistico di
cammarata e quindi con lo stile del
riciclo del mosaico riportano proprio in
tema pour elle in tutti i pesci dello
stretto sul muro di mare grosso e infine
si decide di fare un upgrade cioè la
stretta è molto bello ma non deve
limitarsi a dipingere i muri e allora
come potete vedere collettivo fx e
decide di incorporare il traliccio della
luce e farlo diventare l'albero della
feluca quindi non si limita appunto
semplicemente a disegnare ma incorpora
in qualche maniera l'urbano facendo
un'opera potentissima tra l'altro il blu
in qualche maniera e riporta veramente
la matrice originale giovanni cammarata
non contenti di questo chiamiamo l'anno
successivo un giovane artista messinese
giuseppe raffaele e gli chiediamo di
entrare in relazione con quest'opera
d'arte perché spesso la street art è un
po sembra un po zapping che ogni cosa
non c'entra niente con quella precedente
ed ecco che invece gli facciamo fare
solo col fil di ferro un pesce spada in
fiocinato dalla feluca e in qualche
maniera forse qua si vede ancora meglio
si vede anche lo scenario che c'è
intorno
insomma non saprei come dirla
diversamente ma quello che probabilmente
era il marciapiede il quartiere più
disperato a un certo punto di vista
della città di messina è diventato in
questi anni una specie di laboratorio
urbano in grado di attirare linguaggi ed
energia
se tenete conto che l'unica zona
edificabile della città di messina
quando un po dappertutto ci sono
arrivate l'unica zona edificabile è male
grosso il rischio che la prossima
speculazione fosse in quella zona è
molto grossa perché alla fine butti giù
due baracche ti butti giù due capannoni
e potresti devo fare e insomma l'idea
che invece un argine verso questa
funzionalizzazione lo spazio provenga
proprio da un abusivo che raccoglie
posteriormente tutta una serie di
energia ci sembra una storia che valga
la pena essere raccontata e infine se
voi mi chiedeste ma senza svegliarmi che
cos'è l'architettura l'idea che
architettura non è solamente una
solidificazione del passato ma
probabilmente anche un trampolino per il
futuro e questo probabilmente un ri
piccolo ritrovamento che abbiamo fatto è
il primo murales di da città di messina
scrostando un muro abbiamo trovato sotto
un murales che qui l'artista rella ha
portato alla luce è oggi visibile a mare
grosso e infine questa operazione
assenso solamente se si coinvolgono gli
abitanti di maregrosso
e questa in questa foto ci siamo messi
in relazione con la scuola enzo drago
quando è uscito un bando ministeriale
adotta un monumento
la scuola ha adottato casa cammarata e
la pulizia la manutenzione ha come dire
attraversato questi ragazzi che crescono
che finalmente sentono di avere un
landmark in un quartiere
purtroppo letto solamente al punto di
vista sociale
chiudo dicendo che c'è un errore
fondamentale nell approcciarsi al mare
grosso solamente in regime diurno
se noi scendiamo di sera cioè officina
c'è il retro nuovo c'è la casa di
cammarata
insomma mare grosso o berlino sud come
richiamo e le zone industriali della
prigione post industriale della città
sono sempre le zone più adatte a essere
rielaborate con linguaggio artistico
quindi più berlino che versailles
grazie
[Applauso]